hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
today we're gonna go looking for life
elsewhere in the universe I think that
with the discovery of many new planets
around stars over the last few decades
the idea that there might be life
elsewhere in the universe has become
more and more of a scientific project of
course we've always been looking for it
we've been wondering we've been doing
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and so forth but now we
have a more focused idea of where we
might look and a little slightly more
optimistic perspective on how many
places there are out there where life
could be we also talked on this podcast
previously about the idea of the origin
of life I mean if life only ever existed
on earth then the search for it
elsewhere would not be very helpful but
we talked to people like Kade Adam ala
to Sarah Mary Walker about why life came
to exist in the first place today we're
gonna roll up our sleeves a little bit
and think about looking for life and
it's one thing to look for
extraterrestrial intelligence very very
far away today we're gonna talk about
looking for actual living beings here in
our solar system people of a certain age
namely my age came of age at a time when
we were looking for life on the surface
of Mars with the Viking landers in the
1970s it was very exciting but also a
little bit inconclusive we didn't find
any life Mars is a pretty dry planet and
these days we talk a lot about whether
or not Mars might have had life in the
past less so about whether it has life
now but don't get the wrong idea because
there's other places here in the solar
system where life really could exist and
we are actually going to go look for it
today's guest is kevin hand who is
deputy chief scientist for solar system
exploration at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory here in Pasadena California
kevin is educated in physics and geology
and biology and astronomy and planetary
science and all these things mechanical
engineering he brings them together both
thinking about what life might be and
how it might arise and how we might
actually build something to go look for
it his special focus has been on Europa
the moon of Jupiter but he also thinks
about Enceladus and
tighten and tighten and other places in
the solar system typically moons of
giant planets where you can get oceans
underneath giant sheets of ice which
might be just the right conditions for
life to form kevin has a new book out
called alien oceans which is exactly
about this topic looking for life here
in the solar system
probably not technologically advanced
life don't get too excited but it's very
very plausible that microscopic or
primitive forms of life could exist
elsewhere
in our backyard and it's very exciting
to think that we're gonna go look for
them I wanted to mention very briefly
that you know we have a patreon here for
the mindscape podcast you can find links
to it on the podcast web page or just at
patreon.com slash Sean M Carroll but we
also do for the for the patreon
supporters they get ad free versions of
the podcast and also a monthly ask me
anything
episode and now we let the ask me
anything episodes go public this was a
vote taken by the patreon supporters
so only patreon supporters can actually
ask questions but everyone can hear the
answers so I will put these on YouTube
and also the actual patreon post where
my answer is whether the episode with my
answers is put becomes public a few days
for everybody
after I post it at the beginning of the
month for the patreon supporters so
check that out also check out the video
series that I am doing called the
biggest ideas in the universe where once
a week I tackle a big idea talk about it
in hopefully a compelling informal
chatty kind of way and then a couple
days later we'll do a Q&A video about
that so a lot going on here at a time
when many of us are locked down looking
for things to do we're trying to provide
content for everybody so your minds
don't atrophy you gotta be thinking you
got to be moving forward brain wise and
this time of quarantine and with that
let's go
[Music]
Kevin Haines welcome the mindscape
podcast Thank You Sean good to see you
now I've heard that you just got back
from Antarctica and did you find life in
Antarctica not that hard really like
you're not really giving yourself a
challenge here that's right that's why
were you there so our team was testing
out and deploying this under-ice robotic
vehicle that is something that JPL has
invested in as sort of a a win-win
robotic capability that can be used to
study Earth's ocean and Earth's
cryosphere Earth's ice while
simultaneously building some of the
capability is that someday we hope to
deploy beneath the ice of a world like
Jupiter's moon Europa hmm okay so you're
you're there at a place where there was
ice on top of water and sending it into
the that's right sea ice around
Antarctica is something where the thing
you were dealing with had a capability
of digging through the ice or did use
cheat but no we're not there yeah so the
someday we will have this robot encased
in another robot and that other robot
will have the job of getting through the
ice I'm gonna put the whole thing on a
rocket send it to Europa but doing so
doing what I just described getting
through ice even thin ice the ice that
we were dealing with in Antarctica down
at the Australian Antarctic division zkk
AC station they were great partners that
ice is just about a hundred and sixty
centimeters in thickness at least when
we were there that's nothing
nothing except to get through that ice
and then deploy our robotic vehicle
takes chain saws and ice chippers and
all sorts of things and projects that
work to get through even thicker ice on
earth use hot water drills and and just
thousands upon thousands of kilograms
yeah to get through the ice before you
can even start to sample what's beneath
the ice and so as you can imagine if our
dream of dreams is to someday get
through the ice of Europa and directly
study that ocean and what
or maybe alive within it we've got a
long thick is the ice we think on Europa
well that's that's a huge debate there
are the thin shell ifs and the thick
shell is I happen to be on the thin
shell clan you got a plan for a thick
shell if you're so it to be clear by fin
I mean about let's call it 5 kilometers
and thickness so pretty more than 180
yeah exactly
you're not gonna chainsaw through that
okay by earth standards so the the
Antarctic Ice Sheet
above Lake Vostok which is one of these
sub glacial lakes on the continent of
Antarctica the ice above Lake Vostok is
about four kilometers and thickness okay
and that would be considered thin ice on
Europa right and we can't even really
access these sub glacial lakes in an art
in Antarctica easily so even with all of
our human capability of flying down
there and right devices to hot water
drill etcetera so this is depressing me
this is making nothing this is less
likely than I imagined too easily just
dig down into Europa's yeah not for the
faint of heart
so just weird you know the audience here
we don't presumably know anything at all
so we'll get to what Europa is and why
it's interesting but is there a mission
planned to go do this or is this just
planning for future far-off things uh
well so there is a mission that nASA has
committed to called the Europa clipper
mission and that mission is a flyby
mission it will orbit Jupiter and flyby
Europa some 45 or more times and with
each flyby some of which may be fewer
than a hundred kilometers above Europa's
surface with each flyby it will collect
incredible imagery spectroscopy it's got
an ice penetrating radar instrument on
it to essentially sound into the ice
and so it's got all sorts of great ways
of looking at Europa surface looking
into Europa's interior figuring out the
surface chemistry the surface geology
and some of the interior geophysics and
that's from from a remote sensing
mission a mission flying by that mission
does not have any lander on it I'm part
of the clipper mission but much of what
I focus on at JPL is the next step
trying to get a lander down to the
surface of Europa or for that matter
Enceladus a moon of Saturn that is also
incredibly compelling in the context of
alien oceans beyond Earth and places
where we could go to not just find
evidence of life but find extant life
life that is alive today not just
fossils not just fossils and that's a
that's incredibly important in terms of
of revolutionising our understanding of
biology do we know for sure that there
are oceans beneath the ice on Europa
surface well you of course know that for
sure needs to be in quotes but based on
the available evidence we can make the
prediction that the best hypothesis to
explain the available evidence is that
Europa does have a salty subsurface
liquid water ocean and that evidence I
like to kind of partition into three
easy pieces okay kind of taking a page
out of five six and the first easy piece
is use spectroscopy to figure out that
the surface of Europa is covered in
water ice huh and rather than methane or
rocks or what-have-you right think about
it 1610 Galileo turns this military tool
the telescope to the night sky looks at
the moon looks at Venus looks at Jupiter
and sees Jupiter and also sees these
four little points of light which
to him at the time he thought were just
stars right yeah and Galileo being a
clever fellow named them the Stars of
Medici because of course that's where
his money was coming from and he would
name him the stars of NASA that's where
your money's coming from but but as we
know he mapped those little points of
light around Jupiter night after night
and discovered that they in fact revolve
around Jupiter which at the time was
heretical and got him in trouble with
the Spanish Inquisition but through his
diligent observations we came to
appreciate that Jupiter has moods now
those little points of light stayed as
points of light for some 350 years until
astronomers like quite per and Vasily
Moreau a Russian astronomer used
spectroscopy to figure out that the
surface of Europa was made of water ice
mm-hmm so that's the first easy piece
okay we go from a point of light to
Europa having an icy surface like the
next easy piece I like to make the
analogy to babysitting a spacecraft okay
what do I mean I've all done so
babysitting a spacecraft well here on
earth we use the Deep Space Network this
network of antennas three of which are
70 meter antennas to get the data back
from spacecraft and to submit send
commands up to spacecraft this these the
the DSN is used for all missions and
along with collecting and transmitting
data from the various spacecraft the
signals that are received can be used to
look at the tiny red and blue shifts the
Doppler shifts associated with those
signals sure and phenomenally this this
ever ceases to amaze me with the Galileo
spacecraft as it was flying by Europa
the beautiful little gravity well and
you know you're the expert on all of
that and then the fabric of space and
time but Europa has got its own little
gravity well and and as the spacecraft
flies by it causes the Europa's interior
mass distribution and its rotation
caused slight accelerations and
decelerations
which appear as millimeter per second
Doppler shifts in the signal being sent
back to earth so because so you rope
it's not a point mass we can't just
that's right and not only is it not a
point mass but by merit of looking at
the gravity signal of europa in other
words the Doppler shift as the Galileo
spacecraft flew by scientists on the
Galileo mission were able to tease out
the moment of inertia of europa but
sorry we're looking at the Doppler shift
of the spacecraft sending its
transmission factor okay but it's
influenced by Europa and because Europa
is not a point mass it has a shape
that's right it's not a perfect sphere
and that's what you can and not uniform
density right right and so the rotation
plus the non-uniform density puts its
fingerprint on the Doppler shift of the
spacecraft and as it's flat as it flies
and then you can invert those that
information about the gravity structure
of Europa to get things like the moment
of inertia yeah from which you can then
build layered models mm-hmm okay so you
say you such and such rocks it's just
water seconds exactly so the second
piece of the puzzle is that the gravity
data and those Doppler shows necessitate
that Europa at least in kind of a three
layer model has a dense core iron or
iron sulfur a rocky silicate mantle and
then some outer layer of roughly a
hundred to possibly 200 kilometers and
thickness of low dense
material hmm and in particular the
density that fits the gravity data well
is something in the range of one gram
per cubic centimeter also the density of
the glasses of water in front of us
right exactly and so the second piece of
the puzzle follows on the first the
first says you know that Europe is
covered in ice the second piece of the
puzzle tells you that water in some
phase be it liquid or solid extends down
for 100 to 200 kilometers now the
gravity data was not of sufficient
sensitivity to differentiate between the
density of water and the density of ice
sure it's a miracle they could do
anything at all shahnawaz are just
geniuses at taking the tiniest bit of
data and stringing a tale based on this
remarkable but I always feel compelled
to point out we scientists often have
the the easy part of the job it's the
engineers who really make this possible
they they make the data possible yeah
without their precision you don't get
that millimeter per second velocity
difference that you're able to measure
so that's the second piece of puzzle
we're not yet at an ocean that requires
the third piece of the puzzle a liquid
water ocean aside because given the
first two pieces it could just be all
ice that's right exactly and so a third
piece of the puzzle I like to make the
analogy to adhering to airport security
okay what the heck do I mean by that
what do you mean for the moment
disregard those big cylinders that we
sometimes now have to walk in and you
know really have been zapped in a
thousand ways go back to those doorways
the traditional metal detectors when
you're at an airport and you're walking
through one of those doorway structures
you're passing through a pulsating time
varying magnetic field that time varying
magnetic field gives rise to electric
currents in any conductor that you might
have
in your pocket or on your person those
induced electric currents as we know
from Faraday and and um those induced
electric currents give rise to induced
magnetic fields mhm and within the
little doorway there are magnetic there
are sensors to detect induced magnetic
fields so you walk through with the
conductor in your pocket that gives rise
to induce electric currents which gives
rise to induced magnetic fields and the
alarm goes off yeah we've all been there
all been there then you get the pat-down
you miss your flight
so with the Galileo spacecraft the alarm
went off the Galileo spacecraft had
onboard a magnetometer a fancy compass
and as it flew by Europa it detected an
induced magnetic field it had long been
measuring Galileo the Galileo spacecraft
had long been measuring Jupiter's
magnetic field and from that data we
knew that Jupiter Jupiter's magnetic
field is tilted by nearly 10 degrees
from Jupiter's rotational axis exactly
and so if you're Europa Jupiter's
magnetic field has a time-varying
component mm-hmm so the Galileo
spacecraft had mapped that out
reasonably well and as it flew by Europa
on a handful of occasions it detected an
induced magnetic field what the heck
could be giving rise to an induced
magnetic field Oh Europa did not have a
standard dipole the way the earth does
it did not have an intrinsic field it
had this induced field well you could
say maybe the time varying component of
Jupiter's magnetic field is interacting
with Europa's iron core irons a good
conductor yeah make sense that I answer
yes that's off the alarm well you do the
math of the modeling and I did a lot of
this number of years ago and tried to
fit things the core is just too small
and too far away
what about that rocky mantle turns out
that rocks silicate rocks are not
conductive enough to explain the data
but what fits the induced magnetic field
data of Europa beautifully is a near
surface conducting layer now from piece
number one and piece number two we know
that that near surface region of Europa
is water in some phasing and so the best
answer to the induced magnetic field
data at Europa is a salty liquid water
ocean the salt provides the conductivity
that explains a lot about itself would
not work exactly yeah and same liquid
waters better than ice that's right yeah
you know you can kind of play around
with some mushy ice scenarios but even
in that you're essentially at an ocean
anyway I mean it's a it's it's both
remarkable that we can say all that
about a little dot in the sky the
Galileo looked in this telescope it's
also very vivid that we could be wrong I
mean like you said we never know for
sure there's a lot of great evidence but
presumably the Clipper will give us much
more evidence that's right what year is
that coming well so hopefully the
mission will get to the launch pad in
the 2023 to 2025 timeframe okay either
launch would hopefully get us out to jo
I Jupiter orbit insertion and ultimately
flybys of Europa in the late 2020s okay
and a lot of that uncertainty is and
what launch vehicle we actually go on
but it could be roughly five years to
get there yeah on the low end closer to
three and a half four on the higher end
closer to six NASA okay let me pause for
a moment to talk about policy genius.com
those of you who know about my interest
in the arrow of time understand that the
past is something we can understand from
memories and records whereas the future
is up for grabs we
do things today that lead to good
outcomes or bad outcomes and furthermore
things can happen to us that we would
consider to be good or bad we can't
control the future perfectly but what we
can do is hedge our bets and that's
where insurance comes in whether it's
life insurance home insurance auto
insurance and so forth when the worst
happens you have a policy there that
will help you out the trick is choosing
the right policy and that's where policy
genius comes in policy genius is a way
to look at many different offers from
different life insurance companies
choose the one that is best for you
the policy genius team can handle all
the paperwork and all the red tape it
takes the worry out of choosing the best
life insurance for you so even if you
think you've made mistakes that have led
to bad things you'll never be distressed
about life insurance with policy genius
in just a few minutes you can find your
best price and apply a policy genius
calm and then the länder if let's say
that everything works and you get the
länder you get the money get the launch
date when would that be arriving at
Jupiter this is your baby right this is
your thing you should know you have a
quick snappy answer there is no plan for
a 2030s let's say the 2030s that's right
look ideally but but yeah we're we're
and even that does not have a drill
that's gonna go through the ice that's
gonna land on the surface that's right
so the pathway is fly by land and then
get deeper into the subsurface before we
can do a melt probe or something that
gets into the ocean directly we need to
do a lot of ground truth and directly
get onto the surface of a world like
Europa or inside us - to see how hard
that surface is what it takes to drill
or melt into it how thick the ice truly
is in the region of where we want to
someday go through and I should say that
as great as the remote sensing will be
the Clipper mission is a habitability
mission we'll be able to further
constrain the the ocean the ocean
chemistry the ice shell chemistry and
the geology
but unless Europa is extraordinarily
generous with her evidence which nature
sometimes is not right we're not going
to find signs of life with a remote
sensing mission to detect bio signatures
you need to get on the surface I mean
there is a theory that at least some
people have that you could detect really
really complex molecules even if you
didn't know that they had some
particular biological function you might
say there's no non organic way of making
them is that something that's feasible
with just a clipper that's true and so
clipper has on board too very capable
mass spectrometers one of which I'm a
co-investigator on and these are really
exciting instruments and we hope to fly
similar instruments through the plumes
of Enceladus someday and in both case
whether it's flying through the plumes
of Enceladus or perhaps a plume on
Europa instruments such as those mass
spectrometers could give us an inventory
of organic compounds carbon compounds
that provide compelling evidence for a
highly selective process that might
point to biology because really at the
end of the day biology is selective and
abiotic processes for generating carbon
compounds it's not so you basically go
from A plus ion distribution to a picket
fence sorry this is your fancy scientist
way of saying if it's not organic you'll
get a lot of light if it's not molecules
it's not biological sorry I use organic
and the casual way but but you
scientists just mean carbon when you say
organic I understand yeah carbon
chemistry so if it's not a large signal
on there because carbon dioxide of
course is carbon chemistry and that's
not organic so yeah these scientists man
that's why I don't want to have
scientists on my podcast they're just
too thick but anyway you could imagine
lots of sort of random crazy
non-biological chemical reactions that
would occasionally spit out a long
molecule but only in the presence of
many many tiny Maalik
whereas a truly biological thing might
give you this anomalously large
concentration of really long molecules
and coupled with that so life as we know
it the it's really hard to pin down some
of the the fundamentals of life as we
know what do we think would be universal
for the most part of the community
biologists astrobiologists etc there's a
general convergence on biology however
you frame it is selective it will form
larger molecules by utilizing a pool of
smaller subunits in the case of life on
Earth that is for proteins protein Ino
acids RNA DNA right exactly so not
randomly chosen collections of corporate
male right and so if you take RNA DNA
proteins and just break them up you're
going to see a pattern that has a
fundamental unit based on safe amino
acids linked together one two three so
on and so forth right so it's just not a
random smattering yeah now back to the
alien oceans and and having missions
that could fly through plumes on Europa
or Enceladus absolutely there could be
some incredibly compelling evidence but
even after that you're gonna want to
land oh yeah no you don't want to land
more than ever right yeah that's true
and with those chemical analyses you're
not actually gonna see the life you're
not gonna be able to put that under a
microscope until you get down to the
surface and grab a scoop of it and one
of the things that makes me nervous
about depending on flyby missions for
analyzing say plume material is the
small quantities that you actually get
as you fly through a plume and when we
talk about flying through a plume on
Enceladus or Europa it's not like flying
through Old Faithful up in Yellowstone
or even a with the fires here in LA
right or even a snowmaking machine at a
ski resort these plumes at the flyby
altitudes of say 50 kilometers or so
they're very diffuse and so you're
collecting nano leaders too and a good
day microliters of sample whereas if
you're on the surface you're collecting
like a full scoop worth of material and
it's hard to know what you found I mean
I I was a kid you were a kid when the
Viking landers landed on Mars and we all
thought they were gonna tell us whether
there was life and they did some
chemistry experiments and the answer is
yeah like it's maybe there's some hints
but we don't know however so so the
Viking it was a phenomenal mission in
the 70s oh my goodness in the 70 so I
like to compare the Viking missions and
and the the incredible achievement of
the Viking missions that's the sort of
robotic pioneering work that was done in
the in the 70s that is analogous to
putting humans on the moon yeah right
it's a miracle that NASA did that back
in the day when it comes to Viking and
life detection there's a really
important nuance that often gets lost in
the in the mix and when I talk about
Europa Lander Viking often gets thrown
back at me from the naysayers who who
don't like astrobiology or who don't
like the search for life they say you
don't know what you're looking for and
the Viking failed and it killed the Mars
program for decades and that is a
tremendously false read of history for a
number of different reasons but
scientifically what's really important
to appreciate is that the Viking biology
payload was largely designed to look for
living microbes yeah microbes that were
cooking along living breathing
metabolizing enzyme drinking yet right
and so the the Viking Lander again
miraculously scooped up some sample
poured it into a little agar place
little you know
sugar water essentially and did a host
of different experiments looking at
consumption of gasses release of gases
label some of the gases were
isotopically labeled all of those
results required microbes to actually be
living and metabolizing and as we know
that's that's hard to do even in the lab
yeah and so it was a tremendous
achievement but the way in which we
search for biology now is to look for
the chemistry of life the structures of
life and on Viking the measurement the
instrument that kind of put to rest some
of the ambiguous results about the
metabolic experiments was the gas
chromatograph mass spectrometer which
did not detect any organic compounds at
the level of parts per billion mm-hmm
and so the conventional wisdom is if you
ain't got any carbon you ain't got life
yeah at least in terms of searching for
life as we know it and so the the GCMs
results superseded any ambiguity on the
on the biology but this this gets into
what I really wanted to you know use
this opportunity for is to talk about
what life is or might be I mean you're
looking for life in the solar system we
don't know a lot about what it is
previously on the podcast we've had Kate
Adam ala talking about making synthetic
life in the lab we had Sarah Walker
talking about what life is from in sort
of information theory perspective let's
get down and dirty with like the
chemicals and then what might be going
on so how do you conceptualize what life
might be when you're imagining what we
should do to look for it yeah that's a
great question with a myriad of ways to
answer and a first and foremost when it
comes to searching for signs of life be
it on Mars within alien oceans in the
outer solar system on Europa Enceladus
Titan
cetera or on extrasolar planets or with
with SETI signals I think it's really
important to not get too precious about
life hmm
what do I mean by that well the search
for life comes under incredible scrutiny
sometimes very valuable scrutiny but
oftentimes that scrutiny is
disproportionate to the way in which
other scientific questions come under
scrutiny and that's in part because we I
think imbue this question with a certain
amount of preciousness yeah we take the
answer seriously look
I'm certainly someone who thinks that
both the investigation of how life
started and our search for it is way
underfunded and emphasized within the
scientific community excellence
conversion it's an official mindscape
position but I should spend more money
and effort the understanding where life
came from but let me give you an example
in geology there's what is a mineral
yeah okay but fine it's still
operationally you're building
instruments you need an answer even if
it's not the perfect that's right so if
we can remove sort of the precious layer
of how we think about life and biology
then we get to some operational
approaches and fundamentally life is a
layer on top of geology life alleviates
chemical disequilibrium in the
environment to accelerate the increase
in entropy and I don't need to tell you
that we love increasing entropy is our
favorite thing but to that end life does
it in a very chemically specific way by
harnessing the energy available in
chemical systems to do work the free
energy aspects Gibbs free energy that's
exactly
and so that's in this sorry I mean you
and I know what that means but just to
be clear you know very roughly speaking
for those of you who have read from
eternity to here you know that if the
system has energy you can roughly divide
it into useful energy and useless energy
right the useless energy is just all
entropy and temperature the useful
energy that you can do work with that's
the free energy we're talking about here
right and and Gibbs free energy so
Josiah Willard Gibbs a huge fan is one
of these vastly underappreciated
physicists one of the first great
American scientists and can we divert
into Gibbs forever yeah
I'm just no you know no one's these
electrons are free so yeah Gibbs just
vastly underappreciated it is incredibly
humble and and just kind of lived a very
simple life at Yale you know none of the
as much as I love Einstein Einstein sort
of established the crazy physicist
laureate type right yeah and so some of
that persists and like in order to be a
genius and brilliant you must have
something weird it's not the crazy hair
you must have crazy tattoos etc etc and
to me that's so artificial Gibbs was
just ordinary guy with great thoughts
and and so I find his it's very
refreshing to read about Gibbs
well and we're still thinking about the
significance of these concepts for ideas
like the origin of life so I can say and
I will agree that it makes sense that
one of the things life does is turn this
free energy into higher entropy energy
it's not completely clear that there's
laws of law of physics that says that
that should happen or under what
condition it would happen or is it
probable so that's what we have to sort
of empirically figure out that's right
and so yeah let's dive in the Gibbs free
energy for a minute so as you said you
can think about energy in a couple of
different ways the the heat and change
in entropy can't get much time bad and
then there's the work and oftentimes
when we think about work we think of PDV
no pressure and change in volume or
who's a piston we're pushing it in there
it pushes back we're doing work yeah
or you know to go to physics 101 we can
think of work is Force Times distance
and force of course is MA or mg in the
case of planet Earth and so when we
think about the work done we can think
of MGH mass times the gravitational
acceleration times the height to which
you hold something and then yet drop
drop it well Gibbs had this great
insight in that you know within chemical
systems there should be some chemical
equivalent to mechanical work and that
chemical equivalent comes with something
like chemical potential and that
chemical potential times the change in
mass of a given compound within a system
yields you some of that energy available
to do work so can we think of this as
you know if you have hydrogen and oxygen
in a bottle it has the ability to light
on fire and do some work and that that's
right and so Gibbs brilliance right so
entropy is the how do you think about
aggregations where it where do things a
brigade and Gibbs obsessed over this
thankfully so for us Clow seus and
Boltzmann etc had preceded him and and
so he basically said well this this
aggregation and the pressure and volume
changes that's missing a certain aspect
of how we do the full cost accounting
for energy and changes in energy and
keep said you know what if I have
something like hydrogen and oxygen these
two parts
any-any me you'd love to use this term
new parts right so there are these new
parts that get created from old parts so
hydrogen and oxygen come together to
make water and so in any given system
you might have the initial parts
some camp compounds and then at the end
you have new parts and so his addition
to the energy equation which folds into
Gibbs free energy is that chemical
potential for each compound for each
chemical in that system to then react
with other compounds and to form new
parts mm-hmm
so he really helped complete the full
accounting for the conservation of
energy okay but we got to get from here
to life somehow right so I gave you that
I gave that digression beautiful physics
physics and I love it and I can go on
yeah we all like learning new things
the real problem is there are too many
things out there to learn not only does
it take time learn any one of them but
you have to choose which is the most
interesting thing to dive into blink
astiz an app that will help you out with
this it's basically a way boiling down
non-fiction books and condensing them
into just 15 minutes worth of reading
you can read it get the general idea and
move on or decide that you want to dig
in more deeply that's what I really like
about it not that it's a replacement for
books but it's a way to decide which are
the books that you really want to devote
the time to there's a set of wonderful
titles they have such as the biological
mind by Alan jasanoff digital Darwinism
by Tom Goodwin or the science of
storytelling by will store right now for
a limited time blinka Staz a special
offer just for mindscape listeners go to
blankest calm / - cape and you get to
try it free for seven days and to save
25% off your new subscription that's
blink Asst bli nki st.com / mindscape to
start your 7 day free trial and also
save 25% off but only when you sign up
at plinkus comm / mindscape
okay so back to life and why the heck
life arises and here I I'm talking just
about life as a chemical system yep
certainly there is life in silico it's
all sorts of kind of broad organs yeah
yep but strictly speaking for life as a
chemical process that we currently call
biology I think it is if you allow me to
use a loaded term I think it is
motivated by that that requirement of
the universe to increase energy entropy
and in so doing alleviate chemical
disequilibrium in the environment yeah
and so any place where you've got Gibbs
free energy available enzymes which and
how you get to an enzyme is tricky but
enzymes allow you to overcome a bit of a
hump to then release that stored
chemical energy right metaphorically
it's like the spark that could light the
hydrogen oxygen on fire right there
there's some ability for entropy to
increase lurking there in the chemicals
all around you but you have to allow it
to get there somehow and that kind of
enzymatic process is what you're saying
leads to life is life is life jacent
[Laughter]
that's right and so there are numerous
hypotheses for the origin of life itself
but I think one of the most compelling
suspects in the story of how life arose
perhaps on earth and perhaps elsewhere
is the reduction of carbon dioxide
hmm how do you take carbon dioxide and
pull off the oxygens and do something
else with them and sometimes this folds
into
a acetyl co a pathway that is part of
modern biology take your word for that
but but early on minerals may have been
the sort of first catalytic environment
that were kind of the the proto enzymes
mm-hmm that allowed for the reduction of
things like carbon dioxide to then form
organic compounds and then to be a
template for self-replication and
eventually the formation of vesicles
that would someday be called cells yeah
I mean I don't want to get too deeply
into this because we got to talk about
various moons in the solar system but I
mean maybe the quick overview of
metabolism replication
compartmentalization the fate the the
most reporting signals for life well so
I'm a metabolism first er and I think
that a and that's where Gibbs free
energy comes into play you need a
motivation for the the energy dynamics
of life when you tell us the opposing
school of thought well I don't think
it's so much opposing it's just a lot of
different camps are trying to figure out
where the intersection of metabolism
information storage and compartmental it
compartmentalization all come together
everyone agrees you need these three
things exact people put different
emphases on what is the crucial step
right and the replication and
information ten seems to me from my
reading of the community to be the thing
that most people are focusing on whereas
you're saying you're a metabolism kind
of guy right now the information
molecule side
what many of us like to call the
top-down side it's kind of low-hanging
fruit we have the information molecules
you know it RNA and DNA are there in us
now and so we can look at the RNA world
you know the idea that the earliest
information molecule was some form of
RNA or poly nucleic acids P na etc but
the the latter down stops at those PNAS
- you mean down to simpler and simpler
right so top-down approach you can climb
all the way down to poly nucleic acids
and variations therein but how do you
actually bootstrap from where'd you get
them from just from counsel sloshing
around exactly warm small pond right
yeah and so as much as I love the
miller-urey experiment which were yeah
getting amino acids and then some more
complex compounds from a spark discharge
experiment that had some pretty simple
compounds like yeah nothing and water
and ammonia in it you then get amino
acids and some of the building blocks of
life
amazing right just mind-blowing back in
the 50s and so yeah so as I recall that
was I mean basically the conclusion is
it's not that hard to make amino acids
out of random junk right and they
thought well yet tomorrow we'll do
proteins and then we'll do DNA but for
long a little no exactly much harder
right and that it's from that
progression in the 1950s to now where of
course we've had the genetic revolution
Leslie Orgel and others really
spearheaded the RNA world and and that
was phenomenal work and then in the in
1977 going back to Viking right so a
year after Viking lands hydrothermal
vents are discovered mmm here on earth
here on earth not on Mars more europa
for that matter yeah but so much
happened in the late 1970s it's just one
of my favorite scientific periods but so
hydrothermal vents are discovered under
the oceans right so so hot springs at
the bottom of the ocean new oceanic
crust is formed
or fractures in the oceanic crust are
allowing chemical reactions to proceed
that drive hot water and all sorts of
interesting chemistry and so part of
what was exciting about the discovery of
the hydrothermal vents is that along
with the astonishing ecology the biology
that was found there the tubeworms this
is water said fish the muscles etc these
also started to become recognized as
cauldrons for interesting mineralogical
and potentially organic chemistry to
serve as a place where processes perhaps
related to the origin of life could
occur and part of that is simply you
know life is dynamical you don't want
you're not going to imagine that life
forms in a something is just sitting
there stationary you need some shake up
something that is locking things around
and hopefully falling into good patterns
right and and one of the things that I
do like about the hydrothermal vents
model for the origin of life is it's
motivated by a metabolism first approach
you've got compounds coming out the the
fluids are full of things like hydrogen
and methane compounds that have
electrons they just want to give away
mmm energy energy coming back to Gibbs
free energy right and there are minerals
that also want to give away electrons
and the ocean around it wants to accept
those electrons so there's a lot of
really compelling chemistry that occurs
around how to thermal that's the
downside and the argument that's often
put against hydrothermal vents is all
that damn water the water is not deadly
and well but it is to certain chemical
reactions right so when you link two
amino acids together that process that
polymerization spits out a water
molecule so if you're linking two amino
acids together in a liquid water
environment you're trying to introduce
a new water molecule into a place that's
full of water molecules that's not
particularly advantageous my chemistry
doesn't like to proceed in that
direction and that's where many of my
colleagues who do brilliant work on like
warm tide pools on the flanks of some
ancient continent where you can lap up
some primordial soup and then it gets
baked in the Sun and desiccated you know
that desiccation process that's a much
better environment for concentrating
things and linking things together and
they showed it on Star Trek that that
was how life forms must be true yeah now
so those are kind of there are different
camps as far as information first
metabolism first compartmentalization
and then layered on top of there is a
Venn diagram of environments that we see
here on earth hydrothermal vents tide
pools hot springs other things what I
find so exciting about these alien
oceans beyond Earth these worlds like
Europa Enceladus and Titan is that we
can just do this experiment yeah right
well we've done it a handful of times
let's put it that way right what do you
mean I mean the the solar system has
gone exactly right so the solar system
is running these experiments yeah we can
go into our own backyard our own solar
system backyard and just look in the ice
and then the oceans of these these ocean
worlds of the outer solar system say hey
you got life that life originated there
yeah and I do think these worlds are
great places for second independent
origins of life so let me see like if I
have the picture I mean we we know that
certain things are necessary the
compartmentalization the replication the
metabolism we know they're all necessary
but we don't know the order or what led
to what or anything like that there's
various hypotheses and part of the
problem is even though we have a lot of
life currently on earth and even very
simple organisms it's still a stretch to
say what the first organisms were like
right you're like we can't definitely
say that so if we were able to look at
other environments where there was also
the possibility these things going on we
could learn a lot that's right and this
is where it's just beautiful we have a
chance to look at what is contingent and
what is convergent in biochemical
evolution is DNA RNA and protein
chemistry the only game in town yeah if
you run the clock again it does
biochemistry converge on that solution
so what's the answer we gotta go to
Europa would think you think the DNA is
necessary for life so here's what I can
say with confidence that I love Mars I
love doing Mars exploration it's a
beautiful world but but there are two
things first and foremost our search for
life on Mars is primarily a search for
life in the past as preserved in the
rock record and large because there was
running water on Mars right there's Mars
had a wet and watery past so warmer past
and we think that Mars was definitely
habitable and I for one think that Mars
most likely had life I based on what I
know of life on Earth I would predict
that if the origin of life is easy
so they together right but if you grant
me that then Mars had life and there
should be evidence of life on Mars I
would argue that we have strictly zero
information about whether it was easy or
100 because our existence does not count
that's right but what's the best way to
get to turn that from zero to non zero
right look somewhere else there was
exactly that's right okay so but you did
say you bet that Mars probably had life
right you think we have a lot of
evidence that the condition right now
the problem is that let's say we go to
Mars and we find some beautiful rocks
and beautiful stromatolites rocks that
preserve the perhaps the microbial
fabric or fossils DNA RNA large
information molecules do not last for a
long time in the rock record now in the
subsurface of Mars there could be living
life
and I would be thrilled to go and
explore Mars for that but even if we
found DNA based life on Mars Occam's
razor would still tell me I can't quite
count on that as a second origin right
because Earth and Mars too close too
close
you know neighbors planetary buddies
just send them stuff back and forth
swapping bodily fluids right in packs
and you have you know meteorites from
Mars here on earth and people look for
evidence of life in them exactly this
isn't just speculation we actually have
examples the outer solar system is much
harder to say contaminate with with
earth rocks or Mars rocks and so if we
went to Europa or Enceladus or Titan
with a robotic vehicle and we found DNA
based life that to me would strongly
point to a second independent origin
with a convergent biochemical evolution
towards DNA and that was just would be
phenomenal
can you name at least one plausible
alternative to DNA no no no I wish I
could but we admit that that might just
be our lack of imagination that's right
now
Steve Benner in Florida has done some
beautiful experiments on adding
additional base pairs so there are some
interesting synthetic biology
experiments that have been done I've
heard about I think the kata model also
talked about this you know these are the
for the gcta
might not be the whole alphabet that's
right it's not the whole alphabet in
terms of you can you can push at least
in the lab the DNA molecule to to have
added base pairs is that biologically
acceptable yeah we don't know that those
experiments it hasn't gone from cool
chemistry to actual biology
but it's it's really compelling okay but
so we will at least have the ability to
ask so there's one thing that we could
learn I mean obviously the fact that we
if we learned that there's life
elsewhere that's the big thing the
second thing is is it DNA are in a
similar kind of chemistry I'm sure that
some people in the audience are thinking
isn't it too cold out there to have like
way beyond the orbit of Mars why are you
even talking about these rights they're
not a Goldilocks zone that's right so
this comes back to the fundamental
game-changing aspect of these ocean
worlds beyond Earth Europa Ganymede
Callisto three moons of Jupiter Titan
and Enceladus two moons of Saturn and
even Neptune's curious moon Triton these
are worlds where liquid water is
maintained and sustained in large part
through tidal dissipation tidal energy
pumping and stretching and then heating
these worlds from the interior because
these moons are orbiting a humongous
exactly so everybody knows and loves the
tides on earth on Europa you're dealing
with a rope is about the size of our
moon but Europa is orbiting Jupiter
which is some 318 times as massive as
the earth and your rope was just getting
tugged and squeezed like a ball of taffy
and it's the the predictions are that if
you stood on Europa you might rise and
fall in the diurnal cycle the daily up
and down which is equivalent to three
point five five Earth days you might
rise and fall with the tides about 30
meters or nearly 100 feet per your
opening day all right so take your
Dramamine but that's
yes that's injecting a lot of energy
into the ice it would be almost crazy to
think that something wouldn't heat up
and make the liquid water that's right
so the traditional habitable zone the
the way we normally thought about
planets in the early days of astronomy
and planetary science was that the
habitable zone is defined by the
distance from your parent star and
habitability was conceived of as having
a liquid water ocean on your planet's
surface in contact with a nice
atmosphere and then you're off to the
races
yeah and in that kind of conception of
the habitable zone you had this at least
in our solar system Goldilocks scenario
where Venus Earth and Mars were kind of
like those little bowls of porridge in
the Goldilocks store
Venus is too close to the Sun gets too
much energy any water that at once had
it got baked out it's too hot
Mars too far away too cold any water
that it's once had froze out know the
story of Venus and her and Mars is much
more complicated or complicated right
it's atmospheres matter right and they
points in the past did have liquid water
but at least in the modern epoch planet
Earth is in that Goldilocks zone where
it has liquid water on the surface in
contact with our nice thick atmosphere
and the reason we have that ocean our
ocean is because of energy from the Sun
from our parent star these ocean worlds
of the outer solar system are teaching
us is that there's another way to get
the business of maintaining and
sustaining liquid water done tidal
energy dissipation and in part coupled
with radiogenic decay in other words the
decay of heavy elements uranium thorium
even potassium provide enough internal
heat so as to keep some liquid water
liquid and on Europa we think that the
tidal energy dissipation could lead to
an ocean a global liquid water ocean of
some 100 kilometers in depth at 60 miles
in depth that's 10 times the depth of
the Mariana Trench the deepest region in
our own ocean and and and so that tidal
energy is is really changing the way we
think about
habitable environments in our own solar
system would it almost always be the
case that throughout the universe not
just the solar system as we know it
these kinds of oceans so basically
there's there's two possibilities one is
your heated by the star and your like
the earth the other is your a satellite
of a giant planet and regardless of what
the star is doing your heated by these
tidal stresses with those with that
second option always come with an ice
sheet around it yeah so for the most
part and the answer is yes I'll get to
Titan in a second because Titan also has
an atmosphere but I do want to give the
heavy elements the the credit that
they're due and radiogenic decay can
last for a long time Pluto and we're
still kind of understanding Pluto as
this beautiful dynamic world who cares
if it's a planet or a dwarf planet or
what-have-you I just love it as a world
Pluto may well have a liquid water ocean
perhaps with some pneumonia or other
antifreeze mixed in
and if sudo does in fact have a liquid
water ocean it is sustained through the
trickling out of heat from the decay of
these heavy radiogenic elements coupled
with that there's interesting thermal
physics associated with ice shells all
of these ocean worlds rely on ice being
a good insulator ice is a great blanket
but there are different kinds of ice
that serve as better blankets than
others and so on Europa Enceladus
that's ice one ice that that we can grab
out of our freeze yeah
the sort of traditional ice and if
you've ever built a snow fort or you
know walked into an igloo or something
like that you know that you can actually
stay pretty warm if you're surrounded by
my frozen water and told that it's the
snow that does the insulating not the
ice well yes but even ice itself my vast
igloo experience cutting out here
so so snow the poorest material is
definitely better but even ice itself is
not Dutch it is not a tremendously good
conductor of heat but then there's this
other aspect clathrates so a kind of ice
that reconfigures to trap various
molecules clathrate means cage or - - in
cage and so on Pluto the ice of Pluto
the water ice is mixed with nitrogen and
methane and perhaps some ammonia and
stuff and that mixture may help Pluto
have a better thermal insulation to keep
its ocean from there could be life on
Pluto's what you tell me well so okay
let ourselves dream a little bit no
that's all the rica morty episode
they're very upset that they've been
demoted from planet status but so where
pluto kind of falls short is in the way
I like to frame this is the Keystone's
for life are you need liquid water you
need the elements to build life and to
the best of our knowledge life as we
know it at least needs a smattering of
54 elements from the periodic table the
most significant of which are the the
Cheops the carbon hydrogen nitrogen
oxygen phosphorus and sulfur
then you need iron and some some heavy
elements and then the third keystone is
you need some energy and that comes back
to the Gibbs free energy some chemical
disequilibrium Europa and Enceladus and
perhaps even Titan
I think satisfy those three key stones I
think the oceans of Europa and Enceladus
are mixing with a rocky sea floor that
rocky sea floor gives rise potentially
to hydrothermal vents which gives rise
to the elements needed to build life and
the energy needed to power life Pluto
might have a lot of the compounds and
water needed for satisfying the liquid
water Keystone and potentially the
energy Keystone
the methane as I mentioned is a good
molecule and so life could eat or make
that part of what I worry about with
food oh is whether or not it's got
enough of the heavy elements no no it's
got enough is so tiny yeah yeah but its
density is sufficient to indicate that
there's got to be some rock for action
no you seem to hint that Titan was a
weirdo also Titan is my favorite place
to search for weird life weird life life
unlike life as we know I want to qualify
any life is not on earth as pretty weird
but serene you mean substantially
different that's right so and here's
we're coming back to kind of an
operational approach to searching for
life here's where we can start to slice
and dice things in a very pragmatic way
would I look out at Europa and Enceladus
and Titan also has a liquid water ocean
beneath it's icy shell and in that ocean
maybe mixing with with rocks I can
generate an hypothesis about the
prospects for carbon and water-based
life out there in our solar system right
and that hypothesis is founded on
observations of life here on earth so
life on Earth is water and carbon-based
water is the solvent carbon is the key
building block and we can look at all
the extreme environments on earth
Antarctica the hydrothermal vents
etcetera now saying okay water and
carbon-based life is tenacious is always
a little bit of life everywhere on earth
yeah yeah I mean I do whenever people
say that I feel like raising my hand and
saying it's not equally hospitable to
life all these different environments
right I mean there's less life that's
right in the desert in Antarctica than
there is in the rainforest 100% okay um
but there's a little bit of life is a
little microbial life every bet that's
right and please be aware that
oftentimes as when I talk about the
search for life and and life on Earth as
beautiful as the Penguins were in
Antarctica or the giraffes of the
Africans
vanna or etcetera multicellular life
metazoans these larger creatures and the
reason for that is because we all just
present represent represent the tiniest
of twig on the vast genetic tree of life
yet not a lot of diversity within right
the medizone for all of the the shape
diversity we all are heterotrophs we eat
carbon compounds and breathe oxygen to
essentially do a fancy campfire burn
right from from penguins to sea slugs to
giraffes
we're all doing the same metabolic
process whereas microbes microbes holy
cow they have figured out a way to eat
anything and everything from acids to
bases to you know and doing it at high
pressures low pressures you name it
which is extraordinarily reassuring for
the search of life for life else exactly
and so when I talk about the diversity
of life on earth and how we use our
study of life on earth to provide a
bridge for assessing habitable
environments beyond Earth it's it's in
that microbial context so undefined
penguins on the ice shelf of Europa
[Laughter]
octopi or things like that from Titan so
the we can make an hypothesis about
water and carbon-based life on Europa
and Enceladus and even within the water
ocean of Titan and that water and carbon
hypothesis is rooted in our
understanding of how microbial life
works on earth they those oceans
if you transported microbes on earth to
those worlds the evidence that we have
today would indicate that those microbes
could survive so we can we can design
spacecraft to test that hypothesis of
water and carbon-based life water is the
solvent carbon
as the building block tighten along with
having this deep ocean beneath it's icy
crust also has this crazy methane cycle
the surface temperature and pressure of
Titan so the the atmosphere is thick on
Titan it's primarily nitrogen but the
the temperature and pressure of Titan is
such that methane exists in all three
phases a solid like triple point a
triple point exactly so solid liquid and
gas
similar to where Earth resides in terms
of its surface being at the triple point
of water and so Titans got these
seasonal cycles going on and it's
raining down methane and ethane and
potentially larger organics and on its
surface the Cassini spacecraft helped
reveal all of these methane dominated
lakes and seas and this is where things
get weird a lake of methane a lake is
already pretty weird yeah yeah and so
could you have weird life on Titan where
the solvent the the thing that the parts
of life get mixed and combined and the
you know on earth that's water where the
solvent is liquid methane I don't know
the answer to that question yeah nobody
really does chemically the difference
between liquid methane and liquid water
is that water is a polar solvent and
methane is non polar water molecules
have a slight positive and negative
charge on them to to the way in which
the electrons arrange themselves and the
the two hydrogen's and oxygen methane
does not have nothing is like a perfect
little tetrahedron yeah and so in
chemistry like dissolves like
so water is very good at dissolving
other polar compounds that's in part
what allows the chemistry of our biology
to work and of course as you know from
mixing
oil and water oil is for the most part
nonpolar and it yeah separate sounds
yeah that's kind of useful that's kind
of useful right now if you flip the
tables and have a non-polar solvent like
methane could you get enough interesting
chemistry done to really drive
biochemistry yeah you know there is
water that it would be different it
would be different and thankfully last
year--last summer yes my memory serves
everything's a blur NASA selected a
mission to get back out to Titan it's
this phenomenally exciting mission
called dragonfly P I'd by my friend
zippy turtle and and it's out of the
Applied Physics Laboratory in Maryland
this is a mission which hopefully will
launch in 20 in the mid 2030s
I'm sorry it'll get out to Titan in the
mid 2030s way out there it's hard to
plan that far but okay too many missions
so it gets out to Titan in the mid 2030s
parachutes down to the atmosphere gets
rid of its heat shield and all that and
then starts turning on these rotors so
just like the quad drones that you see
and somewhat annoying drone to tell you
right yeah so we're sending a drone
sending one to Mars also I know that's
right now the Mars helicopter has got
it's just got one set of rotors on it
the Titan dragonfly mission is much
larger it's the size of a of a dining
room table and along with looking at the
geology and geochemistry of Titan
looking at the dunes and all the
interesting things that are happening in
the world of Titan we're also going to
be looking for signs of life if it gets
shot down by ornery locals that'll be a
great success right as long as we get a
picture of them before they're yeah
there's a camera on the drone it's it's
just a beautiful mission and and what's
fun about Titan my friend and brilliant
scientist and engineer Ralph Lorenz has
done this calculation where if you could
survive on Titan as a human a lot of
caveats there yeah and kind of have your
own Icarus wings you could fly because
of low gravity thinking exactly I'm glad
that calculation was done yeah taxpayer
dollars at work yes so but that part
that in part helped lead to the
viability of doing a rotorcraft mission
that Titan and search for signs of life
Wow now primarily with that mission and
I'm a co-investigator on that mission
we'll be looking for evidence of perhaps
water-based life that has been erupted
from below but we'll also have our eye
towards the the discovery driven aspect
of science yeah what yeah what if there
there is life that has originated and
evolved in these methane ethane rich
lakes is the trick that we don't even
know how to look for that so I mean it's
a design an experiment it's actually
looking for certain chemicals right and
here again we come back to that issue of
specificity life being very selective we
think that even if life is based on some
chemistry
unlike life as we know it even if life
is weird compared to the to the liquid
water and carbon-based life that we know
it will still have that selectivity and
specificity where it is built on
fundamental chemical unit it'll like
certain molecules more than others right
and so if you do an inventory with
something like a gas chromatograph
mass spectrometer you might see a
pattern even in weird life that
distinguishes it from kind of the
abiotic processes that are just random
and kind of linked together mm-hmm atoms
by atoms
I suppose we should put in a word for
Enceladus that's the other place well
this is phenomenal
yeah I mean when I hear people talk
they're they're more I mean there are
certainly people who think that of all
these Enceladus is the one that is the
most likely to have life I know you
might not be in that there are
intelligence partisans and and like
these these worlds are all beautiful and
and meritorious of exploit your children
yes Enceladus just to calibrate
Enceladus is the new kid on the block
the new shiny object right and so the
Cassini mission just ended and we have a
lot of new data and syllabus and so
there's a lot of excitement about
Enceladus and Enceladus was very
generous wonderfully so so so that's
coming back to Europa and the discovery
of Europa's ocean that took that kind of
detailed physics the Galileo spacecraft
not observe any plumes erupting out of
Europa's ice shell we now think we've
got some curious evidence using the
Hubble Space Telescope and some some
Galileo data for water rich plumes
coming out of Europa but when Cassini
flew by and solidus bang there was these
plumes erupting out of the icy surface
of Enceladus now initially skeptics
myself among them viewed those plumes is
perhaps just a D volatile Tylo d
volatilization of the ice and clathrates
perhaps and other things we see jets of
material
elsewhere in our solar system we see
comets sure producing Jets
so early on some of the evidence for
Enceladus could have been explained by
these plumes being analogous to cometary
Jets where something's just causing
outgassing but as the Cassini spacecraft
flew by and tasted the plumes of water
it also revealed that the plumes have
methane and carbon dioxide a smattering
of organics and for me what really
turned the tide was the discovery of
salts okay what's the definition of a
salt so a salt something with cations
and anions traditionally think of salts
as like sodium chloride potassium
chloride magnesium chloride magnesium
sulfate all sorts of stuff where you can
take a positively charged cation and
combine it with a negatively charged
anion so so that means the life would be
tasty so there's a wire or salts
significant in terms of evidence for an
ocean on Enceladus if you just had water
in the plumes of Enceladus and water
mixed with carbon dioxide and methane
and even small organics those are all
things that we see in comets mm-hmm okay
so no biggie in some sense
no biggie in some sense now still very
excited cool but right now what we see
him in there's a trillion comets in the
Oort cloud exactly and comets the way we
get those compounds like methane and
some of the organics is through the ice
having things like methane and
potentially ammonia and then it gets
photo litical a processed UV light from
the Sun processes it and produces these
larger organic compounds so out in
solidus you could be very conservative
and say now this is an evidence of an
ocean this is just photo chemistry
combined with some D volatilization of
the ice show
but with salts we don't really see salts
on comets right salts are harbinger of
water rock interaction liquid water
leeching through silicon site so for me
when the cosmic dust analyzer on Cassini
returned evidence of salts that was okay
now the sign of water not a sign of life
but once you have the water then maybe
it's life appropriate right and so for
me the the Cassini observation of the
plumes and identifying that the plumes
of Enceladus have salts that gives me a
large degree of confidence that were
actually sampling plumes that are
connected til to a liquid water ocean
below and do we have evidence that
there's an icy crust on the top of
Enceladus yeah yeah absolutely that that
goes back kinda to the first piece of
the puzzle
analogous to you know Europa and I
should of course mentioned that for both
Europa and Enceladus the geology of the
icy surfaces point to very very young
ice very good because right something
has to be resurfacing this material some
sort of geological cycling of the ice
with something below repave the ice of
Europa and the ice of Enceladus to give
you a surface with no craters right now
it's not quiet it's not quiet right now
at Enceladus there's a mattoon fold from
Cassini additional evidence would
corroborate the the ocean hypothesis the
moving of the ice shell a decoupled ice
shell a shell that is kind of
free-flowing and disconnected from a
from a rocky interior that was observed
on Enceladus okay didn't know that so
that really cinches the deal in some
sense yeah some break wood layer in
between the ice and the rock right and
then there is also evidence of hydrogen
and other things that actually point to
potentially active hydrothermal ism
active hydrothermal activity within
Enceladus even things like silica
nanograins have been look and discover
so the people who are very excited about
Enceladus are not just whistling Dixie
and I'm incredibly excited about
Enceladus here's the rub on Enceladus
know if you kind of do a a one-for-one
comparison with Europa so keeping in
mind we're talking to the VI of the
Europa Lander well now that I guess the
hero pole Anders and the Europa Lander
is dead so the oh it's dead oh it's a
technology development effort it's it's
not well okay plan to go to the launch
pad yeah in order to to get it to your
Europa die yes but I'm a soulless guy -
I've published on Enceladus not as much
as Europa but but just doing a again a
full calibration yep Europa is 3,000
kilometers in diameter that's about the
size of our moon it's a moon that we
understand very well we mean very well
given the data available we think that
Europa has been around for the history
of the solar system we think it formed
around Jupiter as Jupiter was forming
and we think that the ocean itself of
Europa has been there for the history of
the solar system billions of years you
know now coupled with that there's some
interesting chemistry that occurs within
Europa's ice shell and Europa's ocean
and we'll hopefully get to that but
Enceladus when it comes to this issue of
time I mentioned that the Keystone's for
habitability liquid water elements and
energy a fourth potentially fundamental
keystone is time how long has that
convergence of Keystone's been around
now that may not be important and may be
that life arises very quickly but if I
were a betting man I would kind of more
time the more chances right and so
Enceladus there is a significant debate
within the the planetary science
community right now about first and
foremost what makes Enceladus tick
what's the full tidal energy evaluation
for Enceladus and how long has Enceladus
and its ocean been around and part of
the kind of thread that people have
pulled on is the the rings of Saturn
rings are not particularly stable right
so the rings of Saturn according to some
no there again this is a heavy debate
it's a wonderful debate it's a beautiful
debate this is why we love doing what we
do but there's a camp in the Saturn
community that says the rings of Saturn
tell us that something big happened not
too long ago because otherwise those
rings should have either collapsed been
pulled into Saturn or been kind of
orbitally evolved out it's not too long
ago might be millions of years not tens
of millions of years just a few decades
ago that's right so so the time scale is
geologic and astronomical but so you
know some of the hypotheses are that
maybe the the rings of Saturn were
created 100 million years ago by a
Kuiper belt object
a pluto-sized object careening into
Saturn and hitting a large moon breaking
it up creating the Rings and a bunch of
the small moons etc and so there is a
camp that says that the rings of Saturn
are young and potentially some of the
smaller moons including Enceladus could
be quite young hmm and if Enceladus and
its ocean are young then you know I kind
of view and sell this as this like
fizzing alka-seltzer tablet that's
that's perhaps doing incredibly
interesting chemistry but I kind of am a
little more interested in a stable world
like your elbow that we know has been
around for a long time and this is this
is good the issue of time because I
would like to put everything in a bigger
context here I mean I think that our
listeners probably are happy to say that
microbes are awesome but what they would
really like is little aliens flying
around in spaceships right and we're not
gonna find that in the solar system I
think is most likely but maybe elsewhere
in the universe so what can we learn
from looking at these other places in
the solar system that might tell us
something about the likelihood of life
multicellular like intelligent life
technological life elsewhere in the
world right so this is a great question
that actually folds in to the second
aspect of Europa and Enceladus and some
of the the chemistry that I find very
compelling about Europa that is
potentially lacking it and tells us and
this comes back to Gibbs free energy and
and redox chemistry the coupling of
reductants with oxidants and we touched
on this earlier that a reductant is a
compound that wants to give away an
electron an oxidant is a compound that
wants to accept an electron and the way
I like to think of it you know my
backgrounds in physics and and it's just
biochemical batteries and you connect
the
the positive and negative terminal let
the electrons flow exactly
so life alleviates chemical
disequilibrium in the environment the
same way that when you buy a battery at
a corner store that battery will store
energy for a long time and it'll
eventually trickle out but you can put
that battery in a flashlight you can
connect that battery to a circuit and
allow those electrons to flow and in so
doing you get work done you get the work
of shining a light on something or
running a little remote-control car or
what have you and the battery runs out a
lot faster because you've completed the
circuit biology does that in our
environment around Earth there are all
sorts of geochemical batteries right and
the microbes tap in who was the
biologist you said that life is just an
electron looking for a place to rest
yeah that's true yeah my friend and
colleague Evert shock loves to say that
you know the energy is like being paid
to eat a free lunch and so you know
you're getting energy out of the this
chemistry that's available in the
environment and so why is this important
how does this tie back to your question
of of squid in Europa another aspect of
what intrigues me about Europa
potentially being a better place to
search for life is the the chemistry of
Europa's ocean mmm hydrothermal vents
active sea floors are great places for
reductants we see that on planet Earth
hydrogen methane etc pump out of our
seafloor and microbes love the
reductants but if all you have is the
reductant if all you have is the
negative terminal on the battery yeah
the circuits not complete nowhere for
the electrons to go nowhere to go right
so you need an oxidant you need a source
of oxidants and on earth a lot of the
oxidants are things like oxygen and
sulfate etc etc and we've got
accidents on Enceladus it's not clear to
me that it has a source of oxidants so
it could have an active seafloor pumping
out the methane and hydrogen but if
there's no good source of oxidants then
it might be kind of game over from a
Gibbs free energy standpoint from from
what life can utilize Stampler Europa
has this beautiful but also somewhat
frustrating surface environment where by
merit of being embedded in Jupiter's
magnetic field
Europa's icy surface is being bombarded
by charged particle radiation electrons
energetic electrons tens of kv2 tens of
MeV electrons ions protons etc are
careening into Europa's surface ice and
that those that radiation chemistry that
radio lytic processing is splitting
apart water in the simplest case
splitting apart h2o into things like h+
o h so the h escapes from the hydrogen
escapes and Oh H can combine with
another o H to form h2o - what is h2o -
hydrogen peroxide exactly the same stuff
that you buy at a pharmacy to disinfect
a cop we know thanks to Bob Carlson and
colleagues and the Galileo's
spectrometer that hydrogen peroxide
exists within the surface ice of Europa
further to that we also know that thanks
to observations by John Spencer and
Wendy Calvin using ground-based
telescopes oxygen o2 exists within the
ice of Europa and we know that things
like sulfate and and other very useful
oxidants exist within the ice of Europa
in large part from that radiation
process mm-hmm
so if the ice of Europa is getting mixed
into the ocean below you now have this
beautiful scenario where the radiation
and the radio lytic processing of the
surface ice creates that positive
terminal of the biochemical battery so
if the oxygen peroxide sulfates etc get
mixed into the ocean they could be
combined with reductants from the sea
floor to help power life yep okay and so
people often say well isn't the
radiation of Europa's surface
problematic isn't it can destroy
evidence for life isn't going to make
landing they're harder yes and yes but
the upshot of that radiation is that it
could also be central to that third
keystone of life the energy component of
life and sulfate microbes all of sulfate
but as I mentioned oxygen is also
president present in Europa's ice oxygen
is critical to the emergence of large
multicellular life on earth so hey wait
that was a big leap you just made I mean
dude don't we first need to make nuclear
cells like right like on actual earth
life happened pretty quickly multi-cell
your life took forever I mean I don't
know if it happened quickly well so
let's so we know that life arose there
was debate about this but some say that
the first evidence for life is at the
sort of 3.8 billion year billion years
ago point in time which would put it
about 700 million years after the origin
of the planet itself
you know 800 million years from in that
range more convincing evidence is
available at three and a half to 3.2
billion years ago then multi so the
cellular life
that utilizes oxygen that doesn't emerge
until about 700 million years ago 650
million years ago 600 million years ago
yeah and 3 billion years right little
microbes bumping into each other yeah
that's right
I don't want to give it to ya and so
there's this long period of those early
metabolisms and then the evolution of
photosynthesis and the you know people
love to talk about life as Darwinian
selection and survival of the fittest
etc predator and prey and all that
that's all well and good but I also like
to say that life is also largely about
acquisitions and mergers and meiosis
that game and you know somewhat similar
to economics could you say it's about
romance and love swiping left and
swiping right but sure we can be
capitalist about it good right so
acquisitions emerges what do I mean by
that well in the early days or
horizontal gene transfer there was also
it's a back and forth is like you know
open source life is open source you know
you give me your code I'll give you my
code
UNIX Red Hat it said so so horizontal
dream gene transfer dominated in the
early days then once things really
started so but I would be mean for those
who don't know it's not just that you
you're a little microbe and you split
and you duplicate your genes and that's
the only thing that happens with the
occasional mutation but also literally
you take in DNA from your neighbor or
give it exactly so it's a crazy talk but
ok you're looking at the biological
github and you're working and splitting
in whatever it is you do yeah merging
but then as things got a little more
complicated you start to be more
compartmentalized and less porous
and then instead of just grabbing jeans
those early microbes started to kind of
subsume other microbes bacteria gobbled
up other archaea or you know back then
who knows but they actually qualified as
my single-celled organisms engulfed
other organisms they acquired their
capability yeah just like you know a
Google would acquire Google self-driving
car yeah so this acquisition
acquisitions and mergers strategy is is
very true in the history of life on
Earth but when did that happen when did
that done yeah so there's a lot of
debate about the the timescales for when
do you when do mitochondria right right
an organelle which once upon a time was
an independent microbe when did that get
incorporated when do the cyanobacteria
that really did the business of
photosynthesis when did a um get
incorporated into other cells and even
the nucleus right there's there's a lot
of debate about that and within the
biology community once upon a time there
were prokaryotes and eukaryotes no
nucleus and and you've got a nucleus mhm
but what the Tree of Life is telling us
and what the study of life on Earth is
telling us is that there's a lot more
about that simple I know yeah it never
is that simple that's why you do physics
instead of biologists F equals MA
exactly it's all you need but so fast
forward to the emergence of
multicellular life because I want to I
want to get you the squids on Europa I
know
uh-huh thankfully life on earth began to
utilize the energy from the Sun our
parent star and was able to start
converting the co2 to oxygen
and the initial stage of that pumping of
oxygen into our atmosphere called the
cause the ocean to rust out you know
essentially oxidizing a lot of the iron
in our ocean forming what we now see as
banded iron formations which are where
we go to mine iron and then once the
ocean rusted out we started building up
oxygen in our atmosphere and once oxygen
levels got to a sufficient level a few
microbes started to realize that if they
teamed up they could collaboratively
utilize the oxygen and some of the
organics in solution to do the
metabolism that we now know and love and
depend upon which is that heterotroph II
of eating organics and burning them with
oxygen so you're saying the transition
to multicellularity was not just a bunch
of random bumping into each other
but it was opportunistic a totally
opportunistic think about it like if we
go back to the battery analogy a lot of
microbes have figured out ways to
survive on the tiniest of watch battery
methanogens and sulfate reducers operate
with with tens of kilojoules per mole of
a negative change in Gibbs free energy
can bear that compare that to the the
hundreds of kilojoules to thousands of
kilojoules that are needed by larger
organisms such as such as us
and so yeah it was an energetically
opportunistic innovation to utilize the
oxygen in the air as the oxidant and
organics in the environment as the
reductant so Europa sohan Europa this in
my dream of Dreams late in the podcast
we can dream a little bit right so the
as I mentioned the radiation processing
produces oxygen in the ice and the ice
of Europa is geologically young
the surface of europa globally is tens
of millions of years old that's the
that's a in a flash of a patent
geologically speaking that's comparable
to the age of our oceanic crust here on
earth and those are some of the youngest
rocks on earth so on Europa if the ice
is cycling into the ocean directly and
that's a that's a significant if we
don't know much about the conveyor belt
type of motion of the ice and what may
or may not be happening subduction
subsumption all sorts of things like
that but if the ice is delivering oxygen
to Europa's ocean on a relatively short
geological timescales timescale you
could have enough oxygen in Europa's
ocean to support organisms on earth you
could get those concentrations that are
found in some of the o2 minima zones in
Earth's ocean okay and there you find
palki worms and the motivation for
multicellular life might be there on
there even without the sunshine yeah so
we should tell the audience you were a
consultant on the movie Europa report
correct and I'm not gonna give away
anything except that yes there's that
and they go to Europa and they find life
yeah do they find life yeah yeah and if
you haven't seen the report that the the
the writing team the production team the
actor is it said oh that was a great
project to be a part of and you and I
have worked on various movie consults
together and had a lot of fun that one
was closer to the real science than most
of the ones well so you know they I
think you and I worked on Thor tuga or
Kenneth Branagh and if we can come to
that but for the most part I don't know
what your opinion is but you know we can
add suggestions and kind of try and
guide the vector of where it will go but
at the end of the day it's no big rub on
us if they don't exactly actually take
our advice with the Europa report my
colleague Steve Vance and I
well this is really close to home as a
car yeah gonna do this can you at least
commit to us that you're gonna try and
get things right and they did they were
absolutely brilliant yeah I love the
movie it was a low-budget movie that
really did a very good like eight
million dollars you know the the zero-g
stuff that they did in most large budget
films and movie magic use a vomit comet
to get zero-g the brilliance of of that
team they used green yoga balls and had
the actors on their backs and on their
stomachs rolling on green yoga balls in
the little capsule to give the
appearance of flowing in space I love
that kind of clever way of going about
things I think that I mean I hope that
there are the squid in Europa I think
that's they'll be very cool
but let's sort of wrap things up with
the lessons for beyond the solar system
that we might get from the solar system
and one obvious thing is if we found so
let's say that we really do a good job
at looking at Europa Enceladus Titan and
we either find life on all of them or
none of them how willing will you be
then extrapolate that to lessons for the
rest of the universe right yeah this is
a great and very important question so
if we do a robust exploration of the
alien oceans beyond Earth Europa
Enceladus Titan Pluto you name it we
will either find evidence of life or not
I think both answers are equally
profound so if we find life then it's
kind of off to the races the origin of
life is easy life should arise wherever
the conditions are right
Europa type worlds are potentially
ubiquitous in our universe and and we
could live in a biological universe
conversely if we don't
find evidence of life on these worlds
that gives us important information on
hypotheses for the origin of life yeah
that would tell me that well
the origin of life most likely does not
occur around hydrothermal vents and it
does not occur in icy environments and
and we didn't talk much about origins
and ice but that's a whole nother thread
or it just almost never occurred or it
almost never occurs but in the case of
not finding life in these alien oceans
beyond Earth I would say then that the
origin of life does require continents
and the warm tide pools yeah types that
would be evidence for them right
so Europa has no continents there's no
rivers and yet tide pools so you know we
can we can add to the information
content even with a null results and
granted and no result would be hard to
come by you'd have to explore pretty
thoroughly but that you're willing to
spend that money well and and the other
thing is that you know Europa's ocean
Enceladus is ocean these are global
oceans and so if you sample in a few
places the ocean flows around and you
can at least have some confidence in the
connectivity but um so then
extrapolating to the sultan to our
galaxy in the universe more broadly if
we don't find life in our own backyard
if we don't find it on mars or within
these alien oceans then i think we start
to enter a realm where life on earth is
a biological singularity it operates in
the truest form of singularity where you
know our evidence for life on earth
would say that it is a layer on top of
biology and and that gives free energy
all these things should you know the
laws of physics of chemistry on top of
technologies are yeah they're so physics
is the base chemistry and geology odelay
are there and then biology is sort of a
thing
see you're saying then we have enough
other opportunities to find life in the
solar system that if we don't it really
does suggest that maybe it's not that
ubiquitous that's right and that's
continents and and and earth-like worlds
are required for the origin of life
now Mars serves as a good template for
that we if we do find evidence of life
on Mars
it could be a standard bearer for life
existing on another world but coming
back to what we talked about earlier I
would be reluctant to endow it with a
second Origin yes because of that
that'd be tricky especially if we're
very similar exactly and so yeah then we
get to this issue of a biological
singularity the laws of physics as we
know it the laws of chemistry geology
etc lead to chemical disequilibrium
Gibbs free energy kind of being a
motivator for the metabolisms of life
and life being kind of a tool that the
universe uses to increase entropy and to
accelerate us to that entropic death
mm-hmm
but if it arises only on earth perhaps
something else is sparking the fire so
what is your final question what is your
favorite solution to the Fermi paradox
of why we have not seen life elsewhere
we could imagine that life is rare that
multicellular life is rare the
technological life is rare or that it
technological life is everywhere and
they're just not talking to us I have a
favor one of these right so I'll answer
this in two parts first and foremost and
I worked at the SETI Institute many
years ago and one of my favorite
experiences as a as a young scientist
was approaching Frank Drake after a
seminar and I was a young intern up at
NASA Ames at the time
and dr. Drake of the Drake Equation yes
I said I've long been thinking about all
this stuff and then it's honor to meet
you and all that stuff and I said well
what do you think would be the the next
intelligent species on planet earth if
you fast forward the the timescales for
what's happening on planet Earth without
missing a beat he said squirrels and
raccoons I thought he was gonna say
dolphins and whales and no but I'm sure
squid right but squirrels and raccoons
in part because they are living and
surviving and developing in such close
proximity to the intelligence that
currently exists they're being selected
for right cleverness right but with
respect to the Fermi paradox my primary
answer is we just have not done enough
searching I think it's a it's a poorly
framed paradox welfare me as I
understand it the original version of
the paradox was if you could build
self-replicating probes they could fill
the galaxy pretty quickly right I mean
we noticed that right the Turing
machines etc yeah and you could populate
the galaxy quickly would we see that
that is kind of a people kind of tuck
that under the rug right so I happen to
think that the center of the Milky Way
galaxy the the is like Manhattan hmm
we're eight-and-a-half kiloparsecs out
from the Galactic bulge we're in the
boondocks you know we're like in
northern Canada trying to connect to the
internet and we're saying you know why
can't we dial up the Fermi paradox is
like you know why doesn't the internet
exist
well it does you're doing the right
place you haven't you know all right
connected long enough
and so I do think that so it's they're
about we haven't found it yet that's
your favorite well I think we haven't
searched in enough ways and in enough
clever ways and by clever I mean we've
got to cover more of the radio spectrum
but we also need to think about optical
SETI we need to think about ways in
which advanced civilizations would
communicate with each other right so
answer a is we haven't searched it
enough answer B comes to that would we
really see them and one of my favorite
answers to this is the dark forest you
know the the if you read the three-body
problem the that trilogy of books that
goes into contact with alien
civilizations etc I highly recommend
that trilogy I want to talk about it but
I don't want to spoil it for people
exploit don't play yeah well it's what
but uh it is worth reading I agree yeah
but but basically the points in blue
correct you probably have the
pronunciation much better than I don't
clothes anyway so the basic point is
like it's not always advantageous to
broadcast your existence
right and and so we kind of take it for
granted there it's I want to talk to us
yeah so that's my Part A and Part B K
answer to the family paradox good well
we'll get some data once you get your
spacecraft up there and maybe around
2030 we'll have you back on the podcast
to talk about results from your Landers
think about it
the year you just mentioned 2030 2035
2040 even how exciting is that
oh it's very exciting the century
decades exactly so whether it's
dragonfly going to Titan clipper going
to Europa hopefully Al and are going to
Europa hopefully a mission that'll fly
through the plumes of Enceladus
exoplanets going gangbusters SETI
hopefully taking on a broader and
broader search and and and surveying
those exoplanets within the next few
decades it's we could potentially answer
this primordial age-old question of are
we alone and that's you know gonna
revolutionize biology it's gonna
revolutionize how we think about our
place in the universe yeah and so for
all of the the pains and agony of you
know trying to operate on these
timescales we do live in a and a
beautiful time where we might transform
the universe in which we live into a
biological universe can't think of a
better anyplace than that Kevin Han
thanks so much for being on the podcast
thanks Sean a lot of fun to see you and
chat with you
[Music]
you
[Music]